وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجمات بطائرات
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق منطقه سي تولا
وبيلكروده دون وقوع اضرار او خسائر بشريه
واضافت ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت
الطائرتين مسيرتين اوكرانيا فوق منطقه
تولا جنوب موسكو وفي حادث منفصل اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط طائر مسيره
الثالثه فوق منطقه بيلكرود المتاخمه
لاوكرانيا وفي وقت لاحق قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه انها اسقطت طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
فوق البحر الاسود
في المقابل قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان قواتها حققت تقدما في الجبهه الجنوبيه
وانها تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه لاتجاه
مدينه ميليتو بول في مقاطعه
جنوب شرق اوكرانيا وتعتبر هدفا استراتيجيا
للجيش الاوكراني فهي بوابه الى شبه جزيره
القرم حيث تقع المدينه على خط سكه حديد
يربط روسيا بالقرمه والاراضي الاخرى التي
تسيطر عليها في جنوب اوكرانيا
القوه المسلحه الاوكرانيه هجومها في
اتجاهات ميلوتوبول وباخموت وحققت قوتنا
نجاحا في اتجاهات
ويتم تحسين المقاتلين الاوكرانيين على
الحدود التي وصلوا اليها وفي اتجاه بخموت
تواصل قوات الدفاع القيام بعمليه هجوميه
جنوب مدينه باخموت قام العدو بعمليات
هجوميه فاشله في منطقه كليجيفكا بدون ايسك
ويستمر القتال العنيف هناك
اعلنت سلطات المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه ان
القوات الروسيه تواصل سيطرتها على الاوضاع
في بلده روبوتينو واتمكنت من اخراج القوات
الاوكرانيه من بلده فيربو فوياج جنوب
مدينه اريخوفو في المقاطعه وقال عضو
الاداره العسكريه المدنيه الروسيه في
المقاطعه فلاديمير روجوف في حديث لوكاله
نوفوستي ان الاعمال القتاليه مستمره في
بلده روبوتينو وان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتكبد خسائر فادحه ولا تستطيع تثبيت
مواقعها وفق